so today's topic something that really
bothers me every father's day this is an
older video but it it kind of represents
a sentiment that I see every father's
day my father passed away when I was
three there was four of us kids within
five years so my mom had to raise four
kids by herself
my mom was a single mother so she raised
both of us completely by herself which
is
[Music]
I'm sorry
I don't know how she phrased three boys
on her own with such grace I've
definitely seen her trying to try to
juggle both mom dad and you know
everything else that she had to be for
herself she did all of it and she did it
all as though she was two people but she
was tough huh she was not a joke say our
car broke down
oh well that's the alternator she was
like when you punch she said you put
your nut go out and you just go for it I
mean I don't even know if that's a thing
and and and that is the best way to
break your fingers that is that is this
this works in movies but it actually
undoes the structure of your fist to
actually do a closed fist this is only
gonna hurt you
know I was racing a single-mother
household so I understand you don't
acknowledge the great work that single
mothers do by taking away the shine of
fathers because all you do is repair the
idea that fathers are replaceable that
fathers are needed and in a time where
we need fathers and kids life at an
all-time high
it seems very irresponsible to push that
narrative children need a male mentor a
lot of them are gonna say they don't and
all this stuff but generally need to
people who don't have fathers in their
lives are far more likely to drop out of
school be lower socioeconomic background
have a harder time in life more
likelihood to be involved in crime all
kinds of statistics it's bad
so yes kids generally do need to parents
ideally they need a male mentor so when
you say this stuff you tell them that
it's not important a couple other things
moms don't tell don't talk [ __ ] about
your father to your kids you got a
problem
deal with that yes but don't buy use
your kids against the fight even if he
may be a bad person it's a bad idea
coming from my own experience my mother
did that it biased my relation with my
dad and so when I would end up spending
time with him it was very difficult for
me because I felt like I was on Team mom
and I was angry at my dad not
recognizing that he was really trying to
make an effort and he went above and
beyond in a lot of ways but I was too
angry based off all the things that my
mom and
good woman didn't mean well and known
what she had a hard life and I can
acknowledge it yeah but it doesn't make
what she did right it does it it really
doesn't so when you say this kind of
stuff you perpetuate that idea and you
know kids girl windup what do those kids
grow up thinking they grow up thinking
right let's see if you have a son you're
a single mom and you tell me that
fathers aren't aren't necessary why do
you think that he's gonna want to be a
father in his child's life if his whole
life growing up you told him fathers
aren't necessary do you not understand
how you perpetuate a cycle and
statistically speaking kids who grow up
from single-parent household or more
likely to not be President they're
preparing their children's lives so why
would you perpetuate that cycle hmm I
struggle with this because I don't think
people realize in which ways they're
being toxic with some of this stuff and
I'm like this is not good
how many times do I have to watch an ad
of a dad being woefully incompetent with
everything he does as if that's the
reality because we are raising a next
generation of children who think i'ma
just do by myself because the other
parents not needed it's not because you
can do it that it's a good idea I could
drive my car with my feet
doesn't make it a good [ __ ] idea
mm-hmm because you can that is a good
idea tell him she really is like the
most amazing mother but she was really
an incredible father truly incredible I
mean if you think your mom was your
father listen you can say your mom was
your everything you can say your mom
filled her role and above and beyond
super love but don't say she was her
father my mom is never gonna be my
granddad she shall stupid that sounds my
mom is never gonna be my sister okay she
can't play that role my mom can't be the
father could be your sister but Bing
Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing it's just
like you know women talk about like you
as a man will never understand what it
feels like to birth a child you'll never
understand what it feels like to have a
period I agree in that same token you're
never gonna know what it feels like to
go through puberty as a man to live at
the experience of a male towards what
are we here no you're not a father you
never will be but it doesn't mean that
you can't be enough you're not a father
soldier boy you are not a father you
your mother but you're not a father you
cannot take the place of the father you
did an amazing job as a mom potentially
from what did it say I mean you made it
potentially you made an amazing job as a
mom and you made the best that you could
you're not being a father and just being
a mother doesn't remove anything from
you and that's the fear that I have that
under fear that's what I understand
whenever you whenever I go and I say
that to people they are quick to jump to
yeah but no no I'm not removing anything
away from how wonderful your mother was
and how she was able to cope with
everything and she probably did all that
by yourself and that's amazing your
mom's a hustler your mom's a G your mom
handled everything but she is not a
father what if your parental fluid then
a happy fluid day for you I mean you
know I guess sure if you identify the
father but you're not a father you're
not a father you're not you're not a
father okay your mother and that is
perfect that doesn't remove anything
from you dad the Father's Day is for
fathers that's it the ones that are
there the one that take care of [ __ ] the
one that I actually in there you know
and the ones that aren't whatever but
fathers it's for fathers your mother
you're a woman you're alone and you
raise your kids alone okay you raise
your kids alone you're a happy mother's
day to you you're not a father
if they're your kid don't have the
father and you consistently talk [ __ ]
about the father to the kids that is
toxic that is tough
yes you're hurt for XYZ reason but if
you love your kids not if you love to
bat maybe you hate him but if you love
the kids mm-hmm you don't talk [ __ ] to
therefore about their fathers to your
kids if you love your kids preach
because it's gonna destroy not only the
relationship that they have with their
father for what it was at that point it
is not
for you to decide what relationship
they're gonna have with that father oh
that's right yes God you have to take an
academy a path and that's oxy
when you say father's garbage or they're
not necessary think about replacing
father's with any racial group or any
gender and saying that to kids all the
time I start growing up
do you not recognize how you biased them
against groups we recognize that a lot
of these isms that we have in our
society whether it's race set all this
stuff gender you know we recognize a lot
of it's socialized do you not think that
you as a parent play a huge role in how
you socialize your children in their
views do you not say that's
irresponsible most single mothers that I
know don't want to be in this situation
would have preferred to have someone by
their side and it's okay to acknowledge
that and still saying you'd still did a
great job yeah
it doesn't remove anything but we just
can't have this kind of rhetoric it's
bad for kids it's bad for you and it's
also bad for fathers so tomorrow's some
way to go which of her toughness it was
something very fragile you know anything
that needs help a person a thing an
animal she will find it and she will
nurse it back to health
that's my mom always very affectionate
very hugging and kissing and all of that
it was always nothing but love
[Music]
mom
I hope you have a beautiful day and I
love you from the bottom of my heart and
I'm thankful for everything you've done
for me okay are you are you saying happy
Father's into your mom on Father's Day
because you missed Mother's Day you
missed Mother's Day and any like oh let
me just say happy brother oh because our
fathers the game you overlooked it yeah
yeah oh Father's Day yeah you know it's
like it's like a stralla g when
someone's like what's your sign and
you're like a toys like like okay what's
your rising moon you're like [ __ ] you
just want a second try you just want to
see if you can crack it right
happy Father's Day mom my Marshall is
the other pilot hi mom
happy Father's Day happy Father's Day
mom happy Father's Day mom the Angel
Soft be soft be strong that's cute oh
that a toilet-paper head hell no if you
want me to wipe my ass with this air -
you don't [ __ ]
[Music]
no gentle touch just the way my mom did
it even except table what unknown no
bones angel sir yeah but I've seen that
a lot you know I've seen a couple of
people like on the social medias being
like and yeah that's the message I have
to you know yep I agree what so I don't
think we missed a point we said
everything we had to say I don't know
about you but that's that's about me
yeah tell us what you think about that
Oh
can we just say there's a lot of fires
going on it but preach lit Amal that
look is fire Oh freeze got it you trim
Oh looking good
can we just stop this video preach oh
how you doing it
hey what's up with that new fame I don't
even know if I'm faded but I feel kind
of drunk commas go watch half the
comments were about your your new look
Oh preach looking good today
oh I noticed some workers have a looking
dusty beside him oh I like that cracking
voice
[Music]